I want to invite you to add [music]
something powerful to your Sadaqah
Jariyah list. We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly. Just imagine
this. You help someone learn wudu, how
to pray, how to recite Surah Al-Fatiha,
every Fajr, Dhuhr, Asr, Maghrib, Isha,
Tahajjud,
>> Tarawih. Every prayer for the rest of
their lives, you share in the rewards.
>> When they [music] teach their children,
and their children's children, the
reward continues for you.
>> For just £100, you can help teach 20 to
60 people rightly
learn salah. Donate today and earn
rewards that never stop.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. As you guys know, Iran has been
uh attacked by um America.
Um obviously, with our side, if we're
going to be consistent from our side,
brothers and sisters, as a Sunni Muslim,
um this is not a Sunni-Shia issue, by
the way. Let's just be uh
honest with that. Uh it looks like it
seems like a geopolitical uh for power
issue. Um
this individual who has died, Khamenei,
if I I think that's his name is, um
you need to understand that they killed
nearly half a million to 1 million
Sunnis in Syria.
Now, like I said before, whose ideology
with? I'll be honest with you, not both
sides. If anything, it would be with
Iran. And if we're going to be real,
okay, it is. We're not going to come and
be with the Zionists, okay? Even though
they are both as well as you talk about,
at least with them, we have
something in common. A lot of things in
common as well. However, this spokesman
here, which I want to get to, in shaa
Allah, is um a spokesperson, okay? And
look what he had to say, cuz Iran has
obviously been attacking back. And look
at the victimhood they have. It's
unbelievable. And Channel 4 News
absolutely humiliates this individual.
Like literally absolutely embarrasses
him. Let's watch it for ourselves.
We are aiming
at military targets.
But the Iranian regime is targeting our
civilians,
our children,
our women, our elderly.
We don't have any
fight, any quarrel
with the Iranian people.
The only objective,
the only quarrel,
is the Iranian regime
murderous
attacks. This is what it's all about.
Now, I'll take some questions, please.
Oh, now now now he now he take some
questions. Look Look how he takes
questions now, guys. Yeah. Okay, and
look how he moves on when Channel 4 uh
someone from the person from Channel 4
asked him a very direct question.
Secunder Kermani for Channel 4 News.
Kermani, the Iranian regime have clearly
done terrible things, particularly to
their own people,
but your prime minister is a wanted war
criminal. You don't have the high the
moral high ground here at all.
This is a war crime.
That's Okay, once again, look at this.
He points behind. Of course, like we
condemn any like these are not our
teachers. These are not teachers. Any
innocent people being attacked to our
religion, it's it's haram. He turns back
and goes, "This is a war crime." A
building that's been struck, we don't
know how many people have died or we
don't know. There's no reports of any
death. Yes, and even if there is, we
condemn it. 100% 100% we're consistent.
We're not We're morally consistent, not
strategically consistent. Okay? Does it
affect us?
Are they killing our people? Oh, we
condemn it. Other people, oh, it's fine.
Not a problem at all. He turns behind of
at the building, one building. And he's
saying that this is a war crime, which
it could be. Yes, it and it it is.
And he's saying that what happened in
Gaza when they flattened the whole place
and killed
maybe 100,000 innocent men, women, and
children,
that's not a war crime. He's been called
out. He says it's a war crime. Look Look
what he says next. This absolute coward.
Targeting civilians,
target You can't make this up. Wallahi
al-Azim, you cannot make this up.
Targeting civilians. Can you imagine I'm
a
I I I
I I murder children. I'm known a
hundreds of children I've murdered and
then I go you know you see you see what
my neighbor done. Is that what did he
do? He killed the child.
They're like my friend you're you're
under investigation argue with saying
you are known to kill massacre children
and you're saying what? Oh, there's
someone out there look you see that man
there he's he's just killed a child.
It's unbelievable. You can't make stuff
like these people you just you just
think to yourself are these people
normal? Are they mentally stable?
thing elderly woman killing murdering
her caregiver from the Philippines and
the Iranian regime is targeting not only
us in Israel. They are targeting the
entire region. What's this guy talking
about? Like I'm going to finish this and
I'm going to go to them the attacks that
they carried out
killed I think 20 or 39 Iranian young
girls in an elementary school which
we're going to read in a minute
inshallah. Let's this
what he doesn't allow the person to ask
a question from Channel 4 to carry on
asking the question.
>> What about the hundred or so school
girls in Iran that are that have been
killed in a strike in that And this must
stop.
This must be stopped. You tell me this
must stop. You done it. What are you
talking about? He's they've attacked and
killed girls in Iran innocent children
and he's saying this must stop. You done
it. Are you condemning yourself? No,
nothing. And this is what we're trying
to do. Yes, next question, please. But
what about what about the the Iranian
school
>> them have others. I'm Lumos from There
you go. Cut him. Khalas. Done. Finished.
Okay. Now let's go to Al Jazeera. Al
Jazeera has said death toll in Israeli
strike on southern Iran school hits 148.
Official reported the death toll from
the attack on the Shajara
Taw Tajwe Tayaw Girls Elementary School
in um
Minab. Okay.
And it says here an Israeli airstrike
has hit an elementary school in Minab a
city in the Horozgan province of
southern Iran killing at least 148
people and wounded nearly 100 others.
Official reports the death toll from the
attack on the
Tyaba girls elementary school in Minab
amid is a massive US Israeli offense
launched Saturday morning.
The strike is a part of wave of joint US
military attacks across Iran that has
triggered an outbreak of regional
violence.
Iran Iran's foreign minister Abbas
um Araqchi shared a photo of the attack
which he said destroyed the girls school
and killed innocent children. These
crimes against Iranian people will not
go unsaid, Araqchi wrote in a post on X.
Iran's foreign ministry spokesperson
Esmail
Baghaei
forgive me I'm pronouncing it wrong
Baghaei also slammed the blatant crime
and urged action from the United uh
Security Council are they going to do
anything? Uh
separately Iran's Mehr news agency
reported that at least two students were
killed by another Israeli attack that
hit the school east of the capital of
Tehran. Okay.
So you can see clearly here the pictures
of the massacre that took in place and
these children have
passed well been killed been massacred.
Is there going to be outcry? Nope.
Nothing because their children
lives are valued more than this.
What has Iran done? Like we know Iran in
the sense when it comes to Syria and the
attack on the Sunnis etc. massacring all
the so many Sunnis and we as Sunnis we
condemn and I'll be honest with you I'm
it's like it's your you know like you
know Piers Morgan you're in a moral
conundrum, okay? In that sense
we are happy that this Khamenei wherever
he is he's died. With all due respect
man. What he's been doing and if you're
going to be consistent anyone that hates
Israel and Zionists and is okay with
what Iran did in Syria you are
psychologically not well and you're not
morally consistent. You remind me of
America. Yes, you're not morally
consistent. However, in the situation
when it comes to Zionists and Iran we
will be with Iran in that sense. But do
you see what I'm saying? They have also
committed atrocities. But religiously
and theologically we have a lot of
differences but the ones that we have a
commonality with the Shias that don't go
to extremes in their religion
that's a different story. But I wanted
to bring that to your attention,
brothers and sisters, inshallah. That's
all I can say. And, as you guys know,
brothers and sisters, we are a charity
that helps teach people how to pray
salah. Today, we're going live. You can
join our live, but I really would
encourage you guys to go to the link and
donate even if it's 100 pounds. 100
pounds will teach 20 to 60 people to
learn how to do wudu, to learn how to
pray salah, do sajdah, ruku, learn Surah
Fatiha, learn Surah Ikhlas. And, we have
salah instructors. We've got the salah
pro app that salah pro mats that we're
printing 70,000 in Italian, German,
French, Spanish, Japanese, and English
this year, brothers and sisters, and
20,000 for adults, 50,000 for kids. And,
we would like you guys, inshallah,
whatever you do, it's a ongoing sadaqah
jariyah. Till next time, assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh. We are
teaching people how to pray. And, every
time they pray, you get to share in that
reward. And, when they teach their
children, and their children's children,
the reward continues. Every Fajr, Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, Isha, Tarawih, Tahajjud,
every recitation, you share in the
reward. For just 100 pounds,
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people
>> like me learn how to pray salah. Donate
today. Donate today. Donate today.